Man do you, did you guys see the, um, the Le this is,
so this is as ridiculous as, uh,
uh, this is like peak 20, 20. I kind of hate when people say that,
but this is the truth. Newscaster.
Bring it when the newscaster said the LA knackers. Remember when she said that,
uh, did you guys see this? I mean, it went viral the other day
about the lady basically was, uh,
talking about Kobe Bryant or wait. No, we should talk about Courtney Bryan.
Yeah, she was,
and it was the LA Lakers and she was going to say Nicks and she said,
LA natures.
And it did not sound like knackers and also nacre is even sounds bad.
So she said it and, um,
and it was so, and it was so like, what the?
Cause you said a quick and there were people that actually thought
that it was an outrage that she said the N word,
which is absolutely insane to me.
Like imagine being so racist, ending sane,
but also you were able to climb the ladder ad as a newscaster
to get to the point where you're like, no matter what,
here it goes, this is the moment I've been waiting for.
When one of the most beloved athletes of all time dies
prematurely, I've got,
I've gotten my chance on the worldwide stage to slip in the
N word and let everybody know.
Like there are people that actually think she said that, and she's racist,
which is so insane.
She obviously made a goof,
but people are going to want, people are trying to cancel this lady.
The fact that this lady even has to apologize for,
not for saying
Nate Kurz is ludicrous, but here it is. And it does sound bad.
A star that was perfectly cast on the Los Angeles.
But again,
the star that was perfectly cast on the Los Angeles
[inaudible] is perfectly cast on the Los Angeles.
And said it did took a break and said the N word took a
break, took, took a breath and was just like, let her rip my babies.
I'm a racist and I can't help it anymore. You know what? it.
Here we go. I know, I know it's taboo,
but gotta say it also the worst time, you know,
it couldn't have been a worse time.
Literally literally could have been a worst time. One of the most famous,
I love it.
Black people of all time died and she couldn't have set it at a worst time,
died fresh one hour before that.
And she had to slip in the N word hilarious. Anyway,
she obviously didn't do that. So lay off her case, it was a mistake.
She meant to say Nicks. I think she said,
which is crazy as it is because Nick's have nothing to do with it.
But that's what our explained explanation was.
I guess she kind of does kind of owe an explanation because it really does sound
like the N word still. Eh,
um,
it'd be great if she just said like a gay slur, like the,
the one that began with AF and he was like, I'm so sorry.
I meant to say fire hydrant and maggots, like, wait,
what? Like really? I just hate gays,
but um, that's I, I just had guys that couldn't help it couldn't help it.
Um, I,
I just think it's how about Ari Shaffir dude,
this guy is a troll. It's the weirdest thing about RD,
man, let me play this or you want to bring it up?
It's the weirdest thing about Ari is like,
I know Ari and he's always been the
nicest guy to me. Like just all I like,
I don't judge people. I try not to judge people unless like,
until I've met them and the guy's like legitimately one of the nicest guy,
like he's so nice every now and then he, Texas,
I haven't talked to him in maybe over a year,
but like every now and then he texts me. Yeah. And he's also done noble.
Like he, he texted me once that comics weren't getting paid enough.
And he was like, Hey,
I'm trying to sign this position petition for comics to get paid.
And I was like, Oh, that's really sweet.
And then he dosed Bert Kreischer with his family and,
and did this. And it's just, it's just, I understand he's
but he wrote Kobe Bryant died 20 years too late today.
He got away with rape because all Hollywood liberals who attack comedy and
rooting for Lakers, but play the, um, the video that, uh,
Rappaport tweeted it. If you look on his, um,
and it's also probably all over YouTube, but, um, but, uh,
yeah, like he just did this thing and here's the thing,
there's the weird thing about, um, let me,
let me actually play it. And then, uh, and then I'll, I'll get to it. I mean,
all day rapid, board's been, it'd be such a sports fan. I mean,
couldn't be posting more Coby. I love Michael Rappaport. He's such a nice dude.
Uh, but no, it's not on his own Instagram. He took it down. No. So I get,
right? Cause one fire is taking too long and I could have found it already,
but I get.
So he linked it up to put it on his computer and play the audio on his computer.
But now I get off because the first thing you do when you type in a lyric comes
up, Archie fare Colby video.
And he just went too far and put Arusha fear and they clicked on all the only
arts fair.
And that's when I get off now it's fine because I'm trying to be an idea and I
don't want to be petty, but here it is, play it right.
In the world. And it's always a bunch of terrible stories.
And every once in a while, there's a good story. Good story comes out.
Guy who got away with rape got his today.
Kobe Bryant is a dog I'm here in Charlotte,
the whole moot team that originally drafted him. Uh,
maybe wouldn't have raped that chicken Denver, if he had been,
if he had stayed in Charlotte with the Hornets. But anyway.
Is that it? Um, it's so weird that he did that.
I know he's a troll and here's the other thing too. People are like, you know,
it's calm. Some people who are defending him were like it's comedy, it's comedy,
which yeah. And then people are like, well, where's the joke. Eh,
and I think, look,
Ari is playing a character that, and he obviously gets off on trolling people.
Like it's what he wants and okay. Uh,
and it's insane to me.
Like it's utterly insane that he wants people to hate him.
Like he's a heel. I get it. Okay. If this was a WWF,
he would be Hollywood Hogan or whatever,
bro. People are not going to know you're joking.
And also there's not really a joke in there.
He's just kinda like trying to get people, egg people on.
And also here's the other thing, dude,
you're going to get your kicked.
Like you're a comedian. People always know where you are.
This when my jaw dropped, when he did this.
And I guess the whole idea is he wants people to talk about it and like that.
But man. I mean,
it's bad to do that.
It's just, I don't know,
man. The other thing too is like, he's like Joe,
Joe, like a lot of people know who he is from Joe Rogan.
And so people are tagging Joe Rogan, come get your boy.
Like you've got to think about like that dude. Like,
Oh God, I don't understand when people like want to be.
So I don't under, I don't even know. I don't even get it.
Like I just don't get how isn't the idea as a comedian to put butts in seats.
Like people are just going to boycott you.
I guess he's trying to find the real dregs of the earth that are just like,
yeah. That's a weird fan base though, man.
I mean people, even comedians are so mad.
Cause that's the thing it's kind of bad for comedy to do like that because
people are like, Oh, well he's going to hide. Here we go. Hide him behind.
Like it's a joke. And you're going to just say, it's a joke. Right.
And comedians just can say anything without repercussions. And it's like, yeah,
well we're supposed to be able to,
but also make it Mo funnier than that. Dude,
make it a little bit, I don't know,
wink or something.
So you don't get killed. It's a,
it's a weird thing for me to see dude. Cause like I said,
art has always been super nice to me and to see him let's do that is just so
weird. What a lunatic,
what a lunatic dude.
I always think it's weird. You know, I don't know if Ari does this or not,
but I'm talking about something else now.
But like I always think it's weird that when like somebody dies or whatever the
something happens, kid gets molested and it gets exposed like comedians,
just race to Twitter and like are like, ah, let me come up with the best jokes.
So it'll pop off and it's just like, dude, give it time man.
Or like what about the families? I guess, you know,
I honestly felt weird posting. I haven't posted since Colby died.
Cause I felt weird because I don't really post about
serious. You know,
I've kind of made it a point to not post about serious because I don't,
you know, it's comedy, I want to do comedy mostly the 95% of the time.
Um, I'd probably do it more than 95% of the time,
but so serious posts always kind of make me feel weird to
do as a comedian. And I'm not saying I never do it or I should,
or you should never do it if you are a comedian. But um.
I totally lost my train of thought, but yeah, I just,
I just feel like it's weird to even post about anything
besides Coby right now because everybody knows about it and it would just
be weird to be like, here's a funny video I made, uh,
I guess out of respect, I don't know, morning. I don't know. Uh,
not sure, really.
I don't know what to say about that RA thing, man. That was crazy. Um,
and here's the other thing too. Like people are like, I want to them up.
I want to beat the out of him. That's not the answer either. I mean,
I know there's a bit that, uh, I don't want to ruin the bit,
but what's his name? Chris DiStefano mate was doing this funny bit about how,
uh, very generally like people, people, I love Chris DiStefano,
man love this dude. And it was, he was talking about how,
uh, people need to get people on Twitter,
say anything because they're behind a keyboard and they need to get punched in
the mouth though. Like you need to get punched in the mouth South.
They need to get punched by then.
That's a reason why they're behind their keyboards because they need to get
punched in the mouth. Whatever. It's hilarious. Obviously what I said,
wasn't just funny because it's not my bit and I just was explaining it. But um,
and I don't want to say the funny part because it's his material.
You should go see him. But um, he, uh, you know,
punched in the mouth is one thing, but like people are like tweeting addresses.
They're tweeting like that is crazy, bro. These people need to get,
get checked, punched in the mouth is one thing, but dude, don't incite a mob.
That is insane to be like, all right, well this is your address.
This is a person's address. This is everyone's address. Go ahead.
Like that's I don't know. I don't think that's the answer, man.
I don't think that's the answer. I know some people have done some bad,
but you got to let the, whatever it is,
the authorities or the people that are the powers that be.